Welcome back.
In the previous video we had
this very positive scenario,
where I had originally bought
a house for $1.5 million.
Then a year later, the value of
the house, or at least my
perceived value of the house,
went up to $1.5 million,
because my neighbors sold
their identical
house for $1.5 million.
And so my initial equity
investment went from $250,000
to $750,000.
And why is that?
Well equity is nothing but, if
I have an asset that's worth
$1.5 million, and I owe
$750,000-- that was my
original mortgage on that
asset-- then what I'm left
with is the equity.
So my equity just tripled.
It went from $250,000
to $750,000.
In this video, what I'm going
to do is I'm going to show
you, well, what can you
do with that equity?
I mean, it's not cash.
It's kind of like this make
believe amount of wealth that
you have. You just
feel richer.
And I'll show you that you can
actually turn it into cash
using something called
a home equity loan.
And I'd argue that this is
actually what drove our
economy from about 2002 to
probably still, to this day.
Although I think we're
in a recession now.
In fact I'm about 100%
sure we are.
But definitely until
about 2006.
So what's a home equity loan?
Well I go to the bank.
I say, wow, bank, I have this
$750,000 of equity.
I wish -- I'm rich, but I
don't have this in cash.
I want to do something, though,
with the equity.
I would like to live
like a rich person.
Well the bank says, Sal,
you know, you're right.
Our only requirement is that
you have $250,000-- or our
only requirement is that
you have 25% equity
in your house, right?
Because they want a cushion in
case you can't pay and they
get the house back, and they
have to foreclose, and auction
off the house, et cetera,
et cetera.
So they said, well, we're
willing to lend you up to 75%
of the value of your house.
So what's 75% of the
value of my house?
So let's see, 1.5 times 75%,
let's see that would be
$750,000 plus half
of $750,000.
It'll be 1.075 million,
I think.
I did that in my head,
it could be wrong.
But it's roughly the
right number.
So the bank says, you know what,
we're willing to lend
you up to 75% of the value
of your asset.
And it's of course going to be
guaranteed by this asset.
So far, we lent you $750,000.
So let's see how much you
have more that you
can borrow from us.
Minus -- we're talking millions
-- that's 0.075.
So that's what?
300, that's 250 plus 75, so up
to $325,000 more that you
could borrow.
And what is this?
Where am I taking this
money out of?
Well I'm essentially taking this
money out of the equity
of my house.
And how does that make sense?
Well, what's going to happen?
Let's say I take this loan.
Let's say I say, bank, great.
I want $325,000 in cash.
I want it right now.
So what happens?
Let me draw another series,
another balance sheet.
I stopped using the word balance
sheet, even though
that was the original purpose
of this whole discussion.
I'll draw it a little
bit bigger.
Remember liabilities plus
equities are equal to assets.
So what are my assets now?
So now I have a $1.5 million
house, and I also got $325,000
cash from the bank, so we
can call that 325K cash.
Got it from the bank.
Now what are my liabilities?
Well I have the original
mortgage on my house.
The original mortgage
is $750,000.
This is liabilities
on this side.
Well not the whole side,
we're going to
have equity down here.
So just this is liability,
$750,000.
And then I took a new loan to
get this $325,000 of cash.
So I have a new loan here,
that amount is $325,000.
And this was a home
equity loan.
I took a loan against
the equity that
I have in my house.
This was the equity
in my house.
So what's the leftover equity?
Let me just make everything
clear.
These are liabilities.
These are assets.
And equity is what you
have leftover.
So what are my assets?
I have $1.825 million in assets,
minus -- now what are
my liabilities?
Minus $1.075 -- that was the
max that I could borrow --
liabilities.
Assets minus liabilities
is owners equity.
So let's see, 825 minus 75.
I still have $750,000
of equity.
And that makes sense.
If I just enter into some
transaction where I get cash
in exchange for debt, my equity
shouldn't change.
But now what does happen?
Well I have this cash, and I'm
feeling rich, because I've
never seen numbers
like $750,000.
And that neighbor, that new
neighbor that just bought that
house right next door for $1.5
million, he just bought a
beautiful new Hummer.
And being a very down-to-earth
person, I feel that I also
deserve a Hummer, like my
neighbor, because I am just as
rich as they are.
So I go decide to go out
and I'm going to spend
$100,000 on a Hummer.
Actually, let's not do a Hummer,
because a Hummer could
actually be considered
an asset.
I want pure consumption.
Although I think a Hummer is as
pretty close as a car gets
to pure consumption.
Let's say that neighbor went on
a round-the-world vacation
for $100,000.
And I too, because I did nothing
but sit on my house
and made $500,000 last year, I
feel that I also deserve a
$100,000 vacation.
So what I do is I take $100,000
of this cash.
So I'm now left with just
$225,000, and I have the great
experience of going
on a vacation.
But of course I didn't get any
asset in return for that.
Although maybe your happiness
is an asset, I don't know.
But it doesn't show up on
your balance sheet.
So we had $325,000 in cash.
Now we have $225,000 in cash.
So our total assets went
down about $100,000.
What are our assets now?
It's $1.725 right?
Because we spent $100,000
of our cash.
So what's going to be the
liabilities and equity?
Well the liabilities won't
change, right?
Just because I went on vacation,
the bank's not going
to say, hey Sal, you
owe us less money.
I still owe the almost
$1.075 million.
The $100,000 is going to come
all out of my equity.
So now all of a sudden I
don't have $750,000.
I only have $650,000.
And this isn't the balance
sheet just for my house.
This is kind of my whole
personal balance sheet.
And now my whole personal
balance
sheet, what just happened?
I just took some of that
original equity that I had.
I took $100,000 of it, turned it
into cash, and just went on
a great one-year-long
vacation.
And this is what home
equity loans are.
And this is what, I would argue,
drove the economy.
Or at least took us into
an expansionary stage
from 2002 to 2003.
Because if you remember, a lot
of people were still getting
laid off in 2002, 2003,
but consumer
spending kept going up.
So people are earning
less money, or they
don't even have a job.
How is spending going up?
Well, the values of their
house went up, and they
borrowed against the value
of their house.
They took cash out of it, and
they used that cash to buy
their Hummers, to go on
vacation, to buy fancy
clothes, whatever.
And that drove the economy.
And in the next video I'll
actually talk about, maybe,
why those housing
prices go up.
Or why they went up, in
particular, during this
housing boom, this one that
we're definitely in the
process of getting out of.
See you in the next video.